[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار استهلها بابراز
العناوين
اوكرانيا تعتبر الوثائق المسربه من
البانتاجون مزيجا من الصدق والكذب
المستفيد منها روسيا
الرئيس الصيني وجهه الجيش بتعزيز تدريباته
العسكريه وتحذيرات من حظر صيني على اجواء
تايوان
فرنسا تعلن سياها من تصريحات ترامب حول
زياره ماكرون للصين قبل ايام وتصفها
بالمبتذله
الحكومه الامريكيه تدعو لتنظيم قطاع
الذكاء الاصطناعي ووضع قوانين صارمه على
الشركات الضخمه
[موسيقى]
جدل مستمر تثيره وثائق البنتاجون المسربه
خصوصا فيما يخص الحرب في اوكرانيا كيف
تعتبر ان المستفيد منها هي روسيا وموسكو
تعتبر هذه الوثائق محاوله تضليل وخداع هذا
الملف الاول في التاسعه مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الدفاع الاوكراني اليكسا ان
المعلومات المسربه من البنتاجون عباره عن
مزيج من الصدق والكذب واضاف ريزنكا الذي
يزور العاصمه الاسبانيه مدريد ان هذه
التصريحات تضمنت معلومات استفادت منها
روسيا وحلفاء وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه وجود
قوات لحلف الناتو في اوكرانيا كما ورد في
التسريبات الاخيره
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من موسكو اندريه
المحلل السياسي استاذه اندريه عند بدايه
هذه الحرب بدانا بحرب المعلومات انتقلنا
الى الحرب الدبلوماسيه والاقتصاديه من ثم
الحرب العسكريه اليوم نحن امام حرب تضليل
من المستفيد من هذه الحرب
كحل نجهت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
تضليل روسيا فبتغير الحل الاميركي ستكون
مستفيده من ذلك ولكن بخصوص هذه الوثائق
المسربه المشكله هي ان نحن لا نعلم مصدر
لهذا التسريب
وطبعا هذا ما يدفع روسه
لتشك في ساحه هذه المعلومات انا شخصيا لا
استبعد حتى بان يمكن ان تكون هناك
80 او 90% من هذه الوثائق فعلا صحيحه ولكن
عشره والعشرين الاخرى يمكن ان تاخدوا في
التضليل روسيا خاصه تلك الوثائق التي
تتعلق
بالعمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
بما يخص يعني كم المعلومات او سلاح
التظليل كياف والولايات المتحده كانوا
يقولون دائما بان حرب التضليل والمعلومات
هي الاداه الاساسيه والرئيسيه لموسكو والك
بهذه الحرب اليوم يعني مع انقلاب المشهد
ماذا يعني ذلك
انا لا انا انا اعتقد ان يجب ان ناخذ
موقفا محيدا في هذا المجال عندما نشاهد
مثل هذا التصادم مباشر اذا تحدثنا عن
روسيا واوكرانيا وغير المباشر اذا تحدثنا
عن روسيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
فمحاولات التضليل تاتي من قبل كل اطراف
المعنيه هذا شيء عادي وليس الان هو شيء
عادي كان عاديا في السابق وحتى هذا جزء من
العمليه القتاليه يجوز جزر الكبير لتضليل
الطرف الثاني فلذلك من جيد اقول روسيا
حاليا نعم قالت اليوم بان بانها لا تستعرض
بان هذه الوثائق تحدث
سيناريوهات نحن طبعا لا يمكن ان نستعرض
سيناريو الاخر مشابه لما حدث مع جولان
سانجو الذي قد نشر الكثير من البرقيات
الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه
وتلك البارقيات
الصراع الروسيه الاوكرانيه صراع ازلي
اجاجته الحرب الروسيه الاخيره التي بدات
في فبراير من العام الماضي حرب لا يعرف ان
كانت ستنتهي ام لا الا ان وثيقه
استخباراتيه امريكيه مسربه حددت اربعه
سيناريوهات غير متوقعه لنهايه هذه الحرب
السيناريوهات الاربعه مشاهدينا تحدثت عن
افتراضيات اما بمقتل الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين او مقتل الرئيس الاوكراني
او ازاحه القياده داخل القوات المسلحه
الروسيه او ضربات اوكرانيه على الكريم
سيناريو ضربه اوكرانيا للكراملان يحتمل
ويحتمل مجموعه واسعه من الاثار المحتمله
حيث يمكن ان يؤدي لتصعيد رصيد دراماتيكي
اما باطلاق تعبئه عسكريه واسعه النطاق
والنظر في استخدام الاسلحه النوويه
التكتيكيه او احتماليه دفع بوت التفاوض
على تسويه لهذه الحرب مخاطر مثل هذا
الهجوم من قبل اوكرانيا هي احد اهم
الاسباب التي جعلت الولايات المتحده
متردده في تزويد اكياس بصواريخ بعيده
المدى وفقا هنا لصحيفه نيويورك تايس تتحدث
الوثائق السريه الامريكيه ايضا عن دفاعات
ثياب الجويه الحاسمه لمواجهه الضربات
الروسيه وعن المساعدات الدوليه للقوات
الاوكرانيه كم المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
التي سربتها الوثائق دفعت مشاهدينا
البنتاجون لاعتبار عمليه تسريب هذه تشكل
خطرا جسيما جدا على الامن القومي للولايات
المتحده خاصه لما قد تحتوي هذه الوثائق
المسربه من معلومات مضلله
[موسيقى]
اعود مجددا الى ضيف من موسكو
استاذ اتطرق الى موضوع السيناريوهات
الاربعه يعني البعض منها غير واقعي ولكن
الى اي مدى اليوم تاخذ موسكو هذه
السيناريوهات بعين الاعتبار خصوصا وانها
يعني في حال كانت صحيحه هي مكتوبه لكي
ياخذ فيها المسؤولين قبل القيام باي خطوات
تصعيديه او عسكريه على الارض
انا اعتقد ان طبعا توجد لدى روسيا بعض
السيناريوهات
الاحداث على ساحل الاوكرانيه ولكن في نفس
الوقت روسيا متماسكه بالواقع الواقع يقول
بان يوجد هناك او جارد هناك عده
الاستفتاءات انضمت الاراضي الجديده الى
صفوف الاراده الروسيه وعلى ما يبدو نحن قد
دخلنا الى مرحله الاستنزاف المتبادل فلذلك
علامات روسيا تنظر الى ما يحصل في
اوكرانيا كان امريكا تحاول ان تستغل اقصى
ما يمكن من هذه الازمه لكي تكون هناك اقصى
من الاضرار بنسبه لروسيا وبنسبه
الماليه البشريه الاقتصاديه وغيرها لكي
تستطيع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان
تتركز قبل كل شيء على الصين وقضيه تايوان
وكل تلك الامور بشكل عام فلذلك يعني انا
اعتقد ان يجب ان ننظر الى الواقع يمكن ان
ندرس السيناريوهات ولكن الواقع الحالي
يقول
قد يكون هناك الهجوم واسع النطاق في
المستقبل القريب من قبل الجيش الاوكراني
وهناك حاجه لتصدي هذا الهجوم ماذا بعد هذا
الهجوم نحن لا نعلم بسبب ان البعض يقول
بانه سيكون هجوما ناجحا لبعض يقول حتى في
تلك الوثائق يقال بان هذا الهجوم لن
يستطيع ان يحصل على مكاسب المعاينه فلذلك
نحن بحاجه الى ملاحظه التطورات الاهداف
على ساحه القتال بصراحه كل النزاعات
العسكريه انتهت مبنيين على نتائج التصادم
العسكري على ساحه القتال فما بنينه تطورات
بالضغط العسكريه منذ بدايه الحرب من
المعلوم ان الولايات المتحده او اكياس
استفادت من
معرفه خطوات موسكو العسكريه على الارض
وكشفها قبل وقت ومن هنا اتت ردات الفعل
على كل ما كل الخطط العسكريه لموسكو اليوم
ما سرب من يعني كشف عن الخطط العسكريه
الاوكرانيه هل ممكن ان يفيد موسكو ام انه
ايضا في اطار التظليل فقط
انا لا اعتقد بان روسي يمكن ان تستفيد من
هذه الوثائق بسبب ان في حال صحه المعلومات
في هذه الوثائق فاتمنى هذا سيجبر السلطات
في اوكرانيا والسلطات في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لتغيير كل الخطط فهذا شيء طبيعي
ولكن في حال هذه المعلومات مزيفه فمن جيده
كل الروسي يمكن ان تدرس هذه الوثائق ولكن
في نفس الوقت هي ستعلق قبل كل شيء ليس على
هذه الوثائق بالاعلى المصادر
الاستخباراتيه فهذا سيناريو وحيد بالنسبه
لي روسيا لذلك انا بصراحه نعم نحن ناري
حاليا الدجل الاعلاميه واسع النطاق حول
هديه الوثائق المسربه ولكن هل ستؤثر تلك
الوثائق التي تطورات على الارض هذا السؤال
المطروح ولكن انا اشك في ذلك بسبب يعني
كما اقول هناك عده العوامل التي قد تغير
اما الموقف الاوكراني والخطط الاوكرانيه
او روسيا ستتجاهل تلك
بان الامريكيين اعتبروا اعتمدوا سياسه
التضليل العسكري منذ بدايه هذه الحرب مع
الجانب الروسي ومن هنا يعني عدم الاخذ
بجديه كل هذه التفاصيل شكرا لك استاذ
اندريه السياسي حدثنا من موسكو
اكدت المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا زخرفه الناموسكو مصره على
فتح تحقيق دولي شامل بمشاركه خبراء رؤوس
مشيره الى انهم سيحددونه كل المتطورين او
المتورطين في انفجارات خطوط انابيب
يعيش
مصره على فتح تحقيق دولي شامل لمشاركه
خبراء اروس وسيتم بالتاكيد تحديد هويه كل
المتورطين في انفجارات خطوط انابيب نود
ستريم كما سيتم الكشف عن تفاصيل جريمه
وسنعمل كل ما يلزم لمنع الغربي من اغلاق
هذا الموضوع
في لقاء خاص مع العربيه قال عمده مدينه
ماريوبل في مقاطعه دونياس بان الجيش
الاوكراني غادر المدينه تاركا خلفه ارضا
محروقا مشيرا الى عمل سته عشره مؤسسه
روسيه على اعاده اعمار ماريوب
قبل بدء العمليه العسكريه الخاصه كان يعيش
في مدينه ماريوبول 470 الف مواطن والان
نقص العدد الى النصف وفي وقت المعارك كان
عدد السكان نحو 100 الف نسمه الجيش
الاوكراني غادر المدينه تاركا خلفه ارضا
محروقه والان نحو سته عشره مؤسسه روسيه
تعمل على اعاده اعمار المدينه وفي الوقت
نفسه تقوم المؤسسات ببناء 1700 موقع في
عام 20 23 هكذا يستمر العمل وزارنا الرئيس
الروسي لتفقد مسار العمل ونبذل كل جهدنا
ونعمل باسرع وقت لبناء المدينه ولي عود
الناس الى بيوتهم او للشقق الجديده
والشكله الوحيده هي حاجتنا للاسراع باعاده
بناء المصانع ليعمل المواطنون فيها
[موسيقى]
تعى الرئيس الصيني شيجن بينج القوات
المسلحه لتدريب العسكري من اجل قتال فعلي
واكد رئيس الصيني ان بلاده ستدافع بحزم عن
سلامتها الاقليميه والحدود البحريه وستسعى
جاهده لتحقيق الاستقرار في المنطقه واشار
الى ان الصين ستعمل على ضمان الاستجابه
للتحديات المعقده وفي الوقت المناسب
وفي احدث اجراء صينيه تجاه تايوان خفضت
بكين مده الحظر الجوي الذي تفرضه على
اجواء الجزيره الى مده قصيره جدا حيث من
المتوقع ان يؤدي مثل هذا الاجراء الى شبه
شلل لحركه الطيران جنوب وشرق الاسيا
27 دقيقه المده المسموح بها لتعبر هذه
الاجواء شمال تايوان ذهابا وايابا قرار
فرضته السلطات الصينيه في احدث اجراء فيما
يتعلق بالجزيره التي تريد بكين ضمها
وزاره النقل التايوانيه قالت ستخفض مده
حظر الطيران التي ستفرضها فوق الشمال
تايوان من سبع ساعات الى 27 دقيقه فقط في
الخطه الاوليه ولمده ثلاثه ايام ابتداء من
السادس عشر من ابريل وحتى الثامنه عشر من
الشهر نفسه حيث سيؤثر الامر على الستين
الى 70% من الرحلات بين الشمال الشرق اسيا
وجنوب شرق اسيا وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه
قالت ان الحظر مفرود من جانب الصين وليست
تايوان وان منطقه حظر الطيران تقع في حدود
منطقه التعريف الدفاع الجوي لتايوان رجحت
الوزاره ان حظر الطيران يتعلق بشكل اساسي
بنشاطات فضائيه صينيه او اطلاق قمر
اصطناعي
كانت اجرت خلال الايام القليله الماضيه
مناورات عسكريه ودفعت ببعض طائراتها
وقطاعها البحريه العسكريه الى ما بعد الخط
الذي يفصل مضيق التايوان منصفه بين
البلدين ويشكل خط المواجهه بينهما في
سيناريو لفرض حصار على الجزيره وحظر جوي
وبحري كان التقارير استخباراتيه توقعت ان
تلجا الصين الى الحصار بدلا من الغزو
المباشر حصار يبدو ان بيكين بداته ب 27
دقيقه في خطتها الاوليه كما سمتها
للحديث اكثر مشاهدينا عن الخطوات الصينيه
المرتقبه في المرحله المقبله ينضم الينا
في الاستوديو الصحافه الصيني اهلا وسهلا
بك استاذ الهام يعني البعض يصف ما تقوم به
الصين اليوم بانه غزو تدريجي لتايوان يعني
فهم رده فعل العالم كي لا تقدم على خطوه
تندم عليها كما فعلت روسيا يعني بالتحليل
الغربي اليوم هل هذا ما تقوم به الصين اول
شيء يعني المصطلح غزو
حسب اعتقادي مو صحيح بالنسبه للمصطلح نعم
الدول العربيه وايضا الولايات المتحده
تعترف بان تايوان جزء لا يتجزا من الصين
وهناك صين واحده ليس هناك دوله اسمه
تايوان هذا معترف بها دوليه وثاني شيء
عندما نتكلم عن التدريبات او الدوريات
محيطه بجزيره تايوان هذا رد
للتحركات من قبل زعامه تايوان
وخاصه لزياره الولايات المتحده واللقاء مع
متحدث باسم مجلس نواب الولايات المتحده
وايضا رد على الولايات المتحده وخصوصا على
الاعمال الاستفزازي لنشر المدمره
الامريكيه في جبهة حريصين نحن نتحدث انذار
جدي ولكن تدرج الخطوات الصينيه هل هي يعني
يعني للطباق الحصار على تايوان ولكن بشكل
تدريجي وليس شكل كامل ومفاجئ نعم اول شيء
يعني هذه التحركات او هذا السيناريوهات
هذه السيناريوهات مؤلمه لمواجهه الاعمال
الاستفزازيه من الولايات المتحده وايضا عن
التحركات المدرجه من قبل السلطات التايوان
بمثابتها السيده زين وايضا يعني هذه
تحركات
للتعبير عن ثقه القوات العسكريه الصينيه
وايضا الدليل على القدرات الدفاع الصينيه
لحمايه عربيه نعم
وجود الحملات الطيران صواريخ مع تايوان
حتى اليوم ولكن اليوم البعض يصف هذا الحدث
اذا ما حصل المواجهه بين الجيش الصيني
اقوى الجيش الثالث في العالم والجيش الاول
الذي هو الجيش الولايات المتحده بانه
ما يمكن ان يحدث بهذا القرن هل الصين
مستعده فعلا لهذه المواجهه او لسا بالنسبه
لمواجهه مباشره بين القوات العسكريه
الصينيه الولايات المتحده اعتقد هذا بعيد
عن النقاش لان بصراحه يعني الجزيره تايوان
مو من المصالح الجوهريه للولايات المتحده
في الحقيقه جزيره التايوان فقط النقطه
للتتويك الولايات المتحده على الصين على
الجهه البحريه البحريه وبما فيها هناك
نقاط
الاخرى اليابان كوريا الجنوبيه وحتى فلبين
وفيتنام لكن بالنسبه للصين تايوان هذا
مختلف تماما اول شيء هذا خط الاحمر للصين
وثاني شيء اراد الصينيه شكل المواجهه في
حال حصلت ابقى معنا استاذ الهام مشاهدينا
هنا ايضا قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الصينيه
تتمتع بالسياده لاجده فيها على جزر بحر
الصين والمياه المجاوره وان البيان
الامريكي الفلبيني يشوه اجراءات انفاذ
القانون البحري المشروع على الصين فلنتابع
مقاله
الصين تعرب عن قلقها واستيائها الشديدين
من البيان المشترك الصادر عن الولايات
المتحده والفلبين تتمتع الصين بسياده لا
جدال فيها على الجزر الواقعه في بحر الصين
الجنوبي والمياه المجاوره لها البيان
الامريكي الفلبيني يشوه اجراءات انفاذ
القانون البحري المشروعه للصين وينشر
شائعات وافتراءات عن الصين لا اساس لها من
الصحه
اعد مشاهدينا الى ضيف الصحافه الهامه
يعني المواجهه في حال حصلت لن تكون محصوره
فقط بين الولايات المتحده والصين سيكون
هناك دول كاليابان ككوريا وغيرها كلها
ستكون مشاركه بهذه الحرب هل تتحضرون لهذا
السيناريو وما خلفيه الموقف الفلبيني
اليوم
حسب اعتقادي يعني المواقف اللي هي حكومات
الفلبينيه المختلفه عندما كانت هناك رئيس
سابق كان نعم مختلف تماما وهناك المناوشات
او المفاوضات مع الجانب الصيني ولكن مع
التولي الرئيس الجديد لفلبيني يعني تغير
هذا الموقف وطبعا هذا بسبب السياسات
الداخليه في فليبين لكن عندما نتكلم عن
الدول
المعنيه
بحرصين الجنوبي بشكل عام يعني هناك مفاهيم
مشتركه بان من الممكن ان تستفيد كل هذه
دول وايضا هل تستفيد الصين من هذا البحر
في الحقيقه هذا البحر ممكن ان تستفيد دول
الجوار منها بشكل يعني
بتحقيق مصالح مشترك لكن يعني بغض النظر عن
عن ما يسمى بالخدود او ال ال ما يسمى كيف
نقول
الاختلافات او نزاعات او الجزر مهما كانت
يعني كان هناك الاراضي المتنازع عليها بين
كثير من الدول ولكن اذا حلل هذه المشكله
بطريقه سلميه وبطريقه يعني عادله يكون
هناك مفيده لكلال لكل الجوانب نعم لكن
عندما نتكلم عن
الفلبين وخاصه يعني للنشر المدمره
الامريكيه في بحر الصين الجنوبي عندما
نتكلم عن الملاحه الدولي الملاحه البحري
نتكلم عن ملاحه البحر لسفن تجاريه ويعني
سفن العاديه ولكن موسوف ان العسكريه
لكل دوله الحق لسيطر على المياه الاقليميه
نعم حرب طبعا بينكم وبين هذه الدول على
نقاط عدى نتحدث كما كل الدول المجاوره
سيطره بالمياه وغيرها ولكن هذه الحرب
ستكون نتائجها ايضا كارثيه على هذه الدول
بسبب شلل التجاره هناك شكرا لك استاذ
الهام لي على وجودك معنا
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
وفد ايرانيه يصل الى الرياض لبحث اعاده
فتح السفاره والقنصليه وطهران تسعى لتنشيط
بعثاتها قبل موسم الحج المقبل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنا المتحدث باسم
وزاره الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني عن
وصول وفد الى السعوديه لاتخاذ الترتيبات
اللازمه لفتح سفاره ايران في الرياض
وقنصليتها في جده كنعاني اوضح ايضا في
تصريحات نشرتها وسائل اعلاميه ان الوفد
سيبحث في السعوديه استئناف نشاط الممثليه
الايرانيه الدائمه في منظمه التعاون
الاسلامي مشيرا الى ان طهران تسعى لفتح
بعثاتها في السعوديه واستئناف نشاطها قبل
موسم الحج هذا وسيغادر الوفد الفني
السعودي الى الذي وصل الى ايران يوم السبت
الماضي سيغادر متوجها الى مشهد غدا لبحث
اعاده فتح القنصليه
استقبل نائب وزير الخارجيه السعوديه وليد
الخريجي وزير الخارجيه السوريه فيصل
المقداد وذلك لدى وصوله الى مطار الملك
عبد العزيز في مدينه جده واوضحت الخارجيه
السعوديه بان المقداد يزور المملكه بدعوه
من وزير الخارجيه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
ومن المقرر عقد جلسه مباحثات ثنائيه
تتناول الجهد المبذوله للوصول الى حل
سياسي للازمه السوريه يحافظ فيها على وحده
سوريا وامنها واستقرارها وتسهيل عوده
اللاجئين السوريين الى وطنهم وتامين اصول
المساعدات الانسانيه للمناطق المتضرره في
سوريا
في الاثناء مشاهدينا بحث وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان خلال اتصال
هاتفي مع المبعوث الاممي الى سوريا سبل
ايجاد حل سياسي للازمه السوريه والجهود
الامميه في هذا الصدد وذكرت وكاله الانباء
السعوديه ان الوزير اكد حرص المملكه على
بذل كافه الجهود للتوصل الى حل سياسي
مشددا على ضروره ان يحافظ الحل على وحده
سوريا وامنها واستقرارها وانتمائها العربي
وان يحقق الخير والنماء لشعبها الشقيق
[موسيقى]
الى فرنسا حيث وصف مسؤول بالرئاسه
الفرنسيه تصريحات الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب حول زياره ماكرون للصين
بانها تصريحات مبتذله وان ترامب كان اول
من قال انه لا يستطيع لوم الصين حينما كان
رئيسا كما اتهم المسؤول الفرنسي صحيفه
بوليتيكو باختيار عنوان للقاء مع ماكرون
حسب بابا حساسيه بين الطرفين وقال المسؤول
الفرنسي ان الرئيس الفرنسي لن يعتذر عن
تصريحاته خلال زيارته الصين التي ادلى بها
من قبل بتصريحات وكما يرفض ايضا الرئيس
الفرنسي سياسه الكونغرس الامريكيه
لاستغلال تايوان للضغط على الصين واضاف
المسؤول الفرنسي ان الرئيس بايدن ابلغ
ماكرون بانه لا يريد حربا معصي
تنضم الينا من باريس مايا خضراء الكاتبه
السياسيه استاذه مايا يعني عندما نتحدث عن
الخلاف او بين الجانب الامريكي والجانب
الفرنسي نتحدث ليس عن ازمه انما عن خلاف
حول الرؤيه الاستراتيجيه التي فيها الكثير
من النفوذ والمصالح الاقتصاديه والسياسيه
طبعا هذا الخلاف اليوم الذي يتجلى
بالموضوع الصيني هل ممكن ان يتطور
بالمرحله المقبله
لا اعتقد انه بامكان هذا الخلاف او هذه
الضبابيه التي احاطت تصريحات الرئيس
الفرنسي من المكروم مؤخرا لا يمكنها ان
تتطور لعده اسباب اولها كان اخر تصريح
للرئيس ماكرون اليوم خلال اجتماعه مع
نظيره الهولندي روتي عندما قال اننا
متمسكين في منطقه تايوان واننا ندعم
ديمقراطيه تايوان ضد اي غزو او ضد اي هجوم
صيني لذلك بالنسبه لي فرنسا ستلتزم الموقف
الكلاسيكي الموقف الغربي تجاه تايوان لان
فرنسا متواجده هناك ليس فقط لتايوان ولكن
لديها واحد فاصله سته مليون مواطن في هذه
المنطقه من العالم في منطقه
ولديها ايضا الكثير من
الدول المرتبطه بدوله فرنسا والتي تحمل
العالم الفرنسي ل تواجدها تاريخي هناك
واذا ما صرحت او بعد هذه التصريحات
الضبابيه للرئيس مكروه الذي افهم بها
العالم نوعا ما ان الولايات المتحده هي
التي تتحمل مسؤوليه كل الاستفزازات
في تايوان بالنسبه لهذا يضر بصوره فرنسا
في هذه المنطقه من العالم قبل ان يضر
بصوره الصين او قبل ان يضر بصوره الولايات
المتحده ابقا معي لو سمحتي كانت تصريحات
تبقى معي لو سمحت سنستمع الى مقاله رئيس
الفرنسي ونعود
او الرئيس الامريكي اتهم الرئيس الامريكي
ترامب في مقابله مع فوكس نيوز الرئيس
الفرنسي مانيويل ماكرون بالتذلل لنظيره
الصيني
بعد زيارته لبكين فلنستمع لمقاله
لدينا هذا العالم المجنون الذي ينفجر في
كل مكان والولايات المتحده ليس لها راي
على الاطلاق قلت لنفسي حسنا مكرون كان
صديقا لي ورايته يلاحق ويزور بكين
اعد اليك يا استاذه مايا يعني عندما نتحدث
عن الرئيسين خصوصا
نستذكر الخلاف الكبير بينهما حينما كان في
سده الرئاسه الخلاف على زعم الاوروبيه حتى
يعني وجهه النظر الفرنسيه التاريخيه
برفض الاحاديه
الامريكيه التي تجلت بعد الحرب البارده
اليوم اعاده تذكير بكل هذا ماذا يعني
يعني الرئيس ترامب هو معروف بمعارضه
بمعارضته لسياسه الرئيس ماكرون لذلك
تصريحاته هي كانت تصريحات مرتقبه وهذه
الانتقادات الذي نوعا ما البذيئه كانت
ايضا مرتقبه ارجع الى النقطه اللب اي
سياسه فرنسا بعدم التبعيه عدم التبعيه
للولايات المتحده
وسلك نهج الرئيس او الرئيس السابق
شارلودوغول الذي كان يتعارض مع وجهه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على الصعيد
الدبلوماسي بالنسبه لي هذا هو التوجه
الدبلوماسي للرئيس وهذا هو الامر الذي
يطفي هذا الانقسام على المجتمع الغربي
راينا ان الانتقادات لم تاتي فقط من
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب بل اتت من
داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي من رئيس اكبر كتله
في البرلمان الاوروبي منفرد فيبر وهو على
راس الاي بي حسب الشعب الاوروبي الذي قال
اننا لا نتبع الولايات المتحده ولكننا
ندافع عن ديمقراطيه تايوان الانتقادات
اللاذعه اتت ايضا من مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
من ماركوروبيو من الكثير من
السيناتورز الذين تحكموا من الموقف
الفرنسي قائلين ان الولايات المتحده ستترك
اوكرانيا للاوروبيين ونحن سنعالج مشكله
تايوان وهذه كانت قمه السخريه لان
الاوروبيون دون الولايات المتحده لا
يستطيعون بالمضي بدعم اوكرانيا لذلك كل
هذه خصوصا تجربه اوكرانيا بالنسبه
للاوروبيين كانت على حسابهم يعني على حساب
اقتصادهم على حساب المعيشه على حساب كل
القطاعات وبالتالي لا يمكن يعني بوجهه نظر
الاعتماد على الجانب الامريكي مجددا شكرا
لك استاذه مايا خضراء الكاتبه السياسيه
حدثنا من باريس
نكمل مشاهدينا مع ابرز تصريحات الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب الذي تحدث
صراحه عن تهديد لزعيم طالبان ويصف
الانسحاب من افغانستان بالاكثر احراجا
لواشطه ففي مقابله مع شبكه فوكس نيوز
الامريكيه قالت ترامب انه طلب وارسل
لزعيم طالبان صوره منزله واخبره انه
سيتعرض لضربه شديده اذا فعل اي شيء في
اشاره الى امكانيه شيء اي هجمات ضد
الولايات المتحده او مصالحها فلنستمع
لمقاله
[موسيقى]
بعثت لزعيم طالبان صوره منزله واخبرته انه
سيتعرض لضربه شديده اذا فعل اي شيء ومنذ
ذلك التهديد لم تحدث اي هجمات من طالبان
وخلال المقابله نفسها تحدثت ترامب لقناه
فاكس نيوز عن الانسحاب من افغانستان في
عام 2021 معتبرا انه اكثر احراجا للولايات
المتحده حيث تركوا خلفهم كل شيء حتى انهم
تخلوا كما قالت راب طبعا عن عدد من الكلاب
معظمها من فصيله الرعاه الالماط تصريحات
ترامب لا تعد جديده فيما يتعلق طبعا
بانتقاد اداره الرئيس الحالي بايدن
والانسحاب الفوضاوي من افغانستان فقد سبق
ان رد ترامب على تقرير سابق اتهمه بالفشل
في الانسحاب بان جو بايدن هو المسؤول
الوحيد عن الفشل بهذا الانسحاب من
افغانستان عام 2021 لكن دعونا مشاهدينا
نستمع لتصريحاته مع
الرئيس جو بايدن هو المسؤول الوحيد عن فشل
الانسحاب الاميركي من افغانستان في عام
2021 والتقرير الجديد الذي اصدره البيت
الابيض ويلوم اداره ترامب على الانسحاب هو
تقرير المضلل
[موسيقى]
خطوات جديه اتخذتها الولايات المتحده
لتنظيم قطاع الذكاء الاصطناعي حيث تدرس
حاليا واشنطن وضع قوانين تنظم ادوات
الذكاء الاصطناعي وتتيح للبيت الابيض وضع
كوابح على تقنيات الجديده مثل تشات تاتي
هذه الخطوه لتشير لانفتاح البيت الابيض
على وضع بعض القواعد الاساسيه في هذا
المجال خاصه وان بايدن صرح سابقا بانه لا
يوجد حكم نهائي فيما اذا كان الذكاء
الاصطناعي يشكل خطرا على المجتمع حيث حظ
بايدن الكونجرس على تمرير قوانين تضع
قيودا صارمه على شركات التكنولوجيا الضخمه
لكن فرصه احراز اي تقدم تبدو ضئيله في ظل
الانقسامات السياسيه بين المشرعين
الامريكيين رغم ان الولايات المتحده
مشاهدينا هي موطن اكبر شركات التكنولوجيا
بما في ذلك شركه اوبن اي التي انشات تشات
الا انها متاخره دوليا في مج ال الانظمه
التي ترعى هذا القطاع حيث ادى افتقار
الولايات المتحده للتشريعات اللازمه الى
اعطاء سيليكون فالي حريه طرح منتجات جديده
للذكاء الاصطناعي دون التحقق من تاثيرها
وقبل طبعا ان تتمكن الحكومه الامريكيه من
وضع القوانين اللازمه
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من عمان رات سمور
الخبير في الامن المعلومات استاذ رائد
يعني قبل ان ابدا بموضوع التشريعات
الداخليه هناك شق اساسي اليوم
يعني هذا الاستنفار الامريكي خصوصا
بموازاه المواجهه مع الصين هو الخوف
الامريكي من ان يعني تسبق الصين الولايات
المتحده بموضوع الذكاء الاصطناعي مما يشكل
تحدي اساسي بالمرحله المقبله الى اي مدى
اليوم الصين متقدمه عليهم بهذه الموضوع
مساء الخير بدايه لا انا لا يوجد مقياس
الان حتى نقول انه والله الصين تتقدم على
الولايات المتحده بموضوع الذكاء الاصطناعي
لكن هذا السباق هو احنا بنعيش تماما كما
حاله سباق التسلح احنا بنعيش المرحله في
سباق موضوع
التطور في الذكاء الاصطناعي فعمليا لحد
الان ما في اي نوع من المقاييس اللي نقيس
عليها ونقول والله الصين الصين مغلقه
الصين ما اعلنت عن الى اين وصلت في هذا
الباب
على عكس الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وشركات الامريكيه الامريكي التي اعلنت عن
ذلك واستعجلت انا اعتقد انه في كان نوع من
بعيشوا في سباق ما بين الشركات اي شركه
بدها تاكل السوق وبدها تاخذ السوق فعمليا
لا انا لا اجد اي نوع من انواع المقاييس
التي قد يعني نقول فيها النصيل تتطور اكثر
من الولايات الامريكيه وان كان هذا يعني
من ضمن الاحتمالات يعني وان كان من ضمن
الاحتمالات الخاصه الوصول الى الذكاء
الاصطناعي العام هو من ضمن الاهداف
والسياسات الصينيه هو ليس بالامر المخفي
استاذ رائد بموضوع التشريعات والقوانين
التي تسعى الاداره الامريكيه لفرضا اليوم
من المعلوم بانها يعني حتى الساعه بموضوع
التشريعات على شركات التكنولوجيا العاديه
ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعيه العاديه هناك
ثغرات كثيره لم تستطع ان ان تسدها اليوم
هل بالامكان الوصول الى تشريعات حقيقيه
بموضوع الذكاء الاصطناعي
لا يعني كما جاء بالتقرير اللي حضرتك يعني
تحدثت فيه انه في انقسام سياسي موجود حول
هذه المساله في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وانا اعتقد حتى التشريع
التشريعات وقولنت الذكاء الاصطناعي داخل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يحتاج الى وقت
طويل لانه يحتاج الى خبراء مختصين
بالقانون لهم علاقه مباشره بالذكاء
الاصطناعي لا يستطيع المشرع الامريكي
السياسي اللي جاي من الخلفيه السياسيه ان
يشرع قوانين خاصه تحكم
الذكاء الاصطناعي هذه هذه المرحله انا
اعتقد تحتاج الى ورشات من العمل الخاصه
تحتاج الى خبراء والخبراء الان كلهم اللي
موجودين داخل الولايات المتحده منغمسين في
عمليه تطوير ادوات الذكاء الاصطناعي ولا
يوجد
يعني بالجانب التشريعي اي نوع من من
الخبراء التقنيين
الصناعه جانب الخوف من قبل ما يعرف بعمال
التكنولوجيا بالولايات المتحده من التطور
السريع لموضوع الذكاء الاصطناعي الى اي
مدى ممكن ان يلعب دور ايضا بالضغط على
ابطائه حتى يستطيعوا يعني ان يدركوا ما
الذي يحصل باختصار لو سمحت
انا بدي ارجع بس خطوه اولى انا سؤالي
الاول عن الصين الحقيقه
التخوفات
بعيشها العالم الان من الذكاء الاصطناعي
دخول لهذا الذكاء الى عالم التسلح صحيح
دخول هذا الذكاء الى عالم الحروب وعسكره
الذكاء الاصطناعي هنا الخطوره في المساله
انا لا اعتقد انه فقط على الولايات
المتحده
بس بدقيقه باقل من دقيقه لا اعتقد انه فقط
على الولايات المتحده ان تبحث عن قوناني
لهذا الذكاء وانما على مستوى الامم
المتحده لانه هذه المساله تحتاج تمس
الحقوق الانسان بشكل مباشر وتمس السلم
الدولي العالمي كمان بشكل مباشر يعني
حول هذا الموضوع شكرا لك استاذ رائد اعتذر
على ضيق الوقت شكرا لك استاذ رائد سمور
الخبير في امن المعلومات حدثنا من عمان
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
يعلن حضور الامير هاري تتويج والدهم
منفردا دون حضور مجموعكر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بعد اعترافه بطاعات
المخدرات نصف الامريكيين يرغبون بمراجعه
اقامه الامير هاري فبحسب استطلاع جديد او
ولدته مجلات فان اربعه وخمسين من البالغين
في الولايات المتحده 54% طبعا من اصل 1500
ناخب موسى الجليل يعتقدون انه يجب مراجعه
تاشيره الامير البريطاني بعدما اعترف
بطاعات الكوكايين والمخدرات في كتابه
اسبير تاتي النتيجه في الوقت الذي تضغط
فيه مؤسسه
ظهرتجفاونديشن المحافظه للافصاع عن طلب
التاشيره الخاص بالامير وكشفها للعلن
لمعرفه ما اذا كان قد ابلغ مسؤوليه الهجره
عن تاريخه مع المخدرات حيث يطلب من
المتقدمين لدخول الولايات المتحده الكشف
عن اي انتهاكات شخصيه للقوانين المتعلقه
بحيازه او استخدام او توزيع عقاقير غير
مشروعه وتؤدي طبعا لرفض المتقدم وعلى
الرغم من ان غالبيه الامريكيين يعتقدون
انه يجب مراجعه تاشيره قال 51% انهم شعروا
ان الامير كان على حق في الافصاح عن
تاريخه مع تعاطي المخدرات في مذكراته
[موسيقى]
قلق او اعلنا قصر باكينج في بيان له حضور
الامير هاري تتويج والده الملك في لندن
لكن دون رفقه زوجته واضاف البيان ان
الامير سيحضر مراسم التتويج في السادس من
مايو فيما تبقى في ولايه كاليفورنيا
الامريكيه برفقه ابنائها
[موسيقى]
خصصت الجهات المعنيه في السعوديه المئات
من الكوادر البشريه من مهندسين وفنيين
ومراقبين وعماله يعملون على مدار الساعه
من اجل راحه وسلامه قاصدي المسجد الحرام
واكدت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين على منظومه من
الخدمات الميدانيه والهندسيه والفنيه
وتنفيذ الاعمال وفق خطط تشغيليه تم
الاعداد لها في وقت سابق
[موسيقى]
الصوره من الحرم المكي مع مراسل العربي
اسامه القاسم اسامه كما كل ليله الصوره
معك من الحرم المكي تفضل
اهلا وسهلا العيال تحيه طيبه لك ولجميع
مشاهدينا العربيه انقل لكم الصوت والصوره
اليوم من هنا من الحرم المكي الشريف
وبالتحديد من ساحات المسجد الحرام بين باب
اجياد وباب الملك عبد العزيز احدى اكبر
ابواب التي يدخل منها الزوار وقاصدين
المسجد الحرام الى صحن المطاف فترككم الان
في صوره مباشره عبر الكاميرا العربيه من
هذه المنطقه التي تشهد الان ازدحاما جديدا
وتوافدا للكثير من الزوار والمعتمرين
الراغبين باداء مناسك العمره نتحدث اليوم
اذا الليال عن هذه الارقام عن الايدي
العامله التي تعمل اليوم في المسجد الحرام
سواء في رئاسه شؤون الحرمين او في
الوكالات المسانده نتحدث اليوم عن سقيا
زمزم التي يتواجد بها اكثر من الف عامل
يقدمون سقيا زمزم التي وصلت اليوم عدد
اللترات المستهلكه الى يومنا هذا اكثر من
30 لتر من سقيا زمزمنا تحدث ايضا اليوم عن
اكثر من 4000 عامل وعامله لاداره تنظيف
وتطهير و المسجد الحرام اذا هذه الارقام
التي نتحدث عنها اليوم بالتاكيد الليالي
هي ارقام تشهد اليوم ازديدا كبيرا بحكم
دخول العشره الاواخر نتحدث اليوم ايضا عن
اكثر من ثلاثه مليون مستفيد من الخدمات
التطوعيه اكثر من مليونين ونصف المليون
لتر من كميات المطهرات المستخدمه في
المسجد الحرام نتحدث ايضا عن اكثر من
مليون وسبعمائه الف مستفيد في التوعيه
الرقميه وايضا اكثر من مليون و600 الف
مستفيد في الارشاد المكاني باللغات ونتحدث
ايضا عن اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين ونصف
المليون مستفيد من التوعيه الميدانيه اذا
كل هذه الخدمات التي تقدم اليوم في المسجد
الحرام لاجل ان يعيش الزائر والمعتمر
تجربه استثنائيه ومثاليه اثناء تاديته
لمناسك العمره وايضا لان يؤديها بكل يسر
وطمانينه وسهوله طبعا الجهات اليوم في
رئاسه شؤون الحرمين والوكالات المسانده
رفعت الجاهزيه القصوى بكامل الترتيبات
لاستقبال ملايين الزوار والم خلال العشر
الاواخر حيث وصلت اخر احصائيه لرئاسه شؤون
الحرمين ان هناك اكثر من 950 الف زائر
ومعتمر في اليوم الواحد اي ما يقارب الى
يومنا هذا اكثر من 20 مليون زائر ومعتمر
وصلوا حتى هذه اللحظه الى مكه المكرمه
نشهد الان ايضا هذه الازدحامات الشديده
هذه المنطقه يدخل منها الزوار والمعتمرون
الى صحن المطاف والمنطقه الاخرى تعتبر
منطقه خروج اذا اتحدث ايضا بهذه المناسبه
عن اداره التفويج والحشود هذه الاداره
التي تعمل اليوم لاجل ان يعيش هذا الزائر
والمعتمر تجربه مثاليه وايضا لكي لا
يتداخلوا في بعضهم البعض عملت هذه الاداره
اذا على تنظيم هذه الحشود الغفيره ليدخلوا
بسلام ويخرج ايضا بنفس تلك الطريقه اذا
هنا ايضا بعض الابواب التي تغلق اثناء
الصلاه فقط لدخول المصلين ثم من بعدها
تدخل منها اعداد هائله للزوار والمعتمنه
يتحدث اليوم عن سته ابواب متاحه لدخول
المعتمرين
وسته ابواب اخرى ايضا متاحه لدخول المصلين
نتحدث ايضا عن استكمال اعمال تهيئه
التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه التي تتسع اليوم
لاكثر من مليون ومئتين الف مصلي وثائق في
الساعه الواحده نتحدث ايضا عن هذه الساحات
التي تستوعب ملايين الزوار المعتمرين خلال
هذه الفتره الليالي شكرا لك اسامه القاسم
مراسل العربيه على هذه الصوره وعلى هذه
الرساله من الحرم المكي
مكتبه الكتب والمخطوطات النادره بالمسجد
النبوي تسخر بالكثير من المؤلفات بشتى
المجالات الشرعيه والعلميه التي عود تاريخ
البعض منها الى السادس من الهجره اذ يحرص
الباحثين في زوار وزوار المسجد على زياره
المكتبه بالمعرفه من خلال المراجعه
الموثوقه التفاصيل برفقه الزميل سلطان
السلامية
[موسيقى]
تتنفس هذه الارفف المزدحمه بالكتب النادره
التاريخ الاسلامي والعلوم الشرعيه وشتى
المجالات العلميه المختلفه والتي يحتضنها
المسجد النبوي ويعود تاريخ البعض منها الى
عده قرون عدد الكتب يزيد عن 7000 كتاب
جميعها مرقمنه يستطيع ان يستفيد منها
الباحث هو الزائر اما عن طريق الاطلاع او
عن طريق
الرقمنه بحيث انه يستطيع ان يحصل على نسخه
من هذه الكتاب اقدم هذه الكتب عمره ما
يقارب 200 سنه يحرص الباحثون وزوار المسجد
النبوي على التردد على هذه المكتبه للتزود
بالمعلومات والمراجع الموثوقه لاستكمال
ابحاثهم والتزود بالمعرفه ممكن تحصل في
هذه الاداره على كتب وتجدها هنا غير
موجوده في المكتبات الاخرى لان اسمها
الكتب النادره وهي الان هنا محفوظه معتنى
بها ولها برامج
[موسيقى]
ترميم وبرامج تعقيم
في الجانب الاخر قسم خاص بالمخطوطات
الاسلاميه القديمه والثمينه التي يرجع
تاريخها الى القرن السادس الهجري ويقصد
بالمخطوطات الاسلاميه التراث الاسلامي
المكتوب بخط اليد وقد عنيى المسلمون
بالمخطوطات عنايه كبيره لكونها السبيل
الوحيده للحفاظ على ما انتجه العقل
الاسلامي
في اداره المخطوطات اكثر من 4000 مخطوط
اصلي واكثر من 500 مصحف مخطوط اصلي يعتنى
فيها وتعرض لي الزوار والباحثين وطلاب
العلم يشهدوا المسجد النبوي منذ مطلع شهر
رمضان اعدادا مليونيه بعد التشغيل بكامل
الطاقه الاستيعابيه دون قيود مقدمه كافه
الخدمات بمختلف اشكالها للتسهيل على
المصلين والزوار من المسجد النبوي سلطان
السلمي العربيه
زعمت صحف او صحيفه التلغراف البريطانيه ان
الدكتور روبرت لورنسن وهو رئيس لجنه
الاطباء المتدربين في الجمعيه الطبيه
البريطانيه ذهب في عطله مع بدايه الاضراب
من جهتها وصفت صحيفه ديلي ميل نبا اختفاء
المساحه الاضراب لحضور حفل زفاف بانه بان
ذهاب لوردس وحده كفيل بان يجعلك مريضا
وقال المنتقدون انه يطلب من اعضائه
التضحيه باجورهم اثناء خروجهم في الاضراب
لكن يبدو انه غير مستعد لتقديم هذه
التضحيه بنفسه
خلال زيارته الشماليه حيث اصول اجداده
اظهر الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن براعت
البراعه في التقاط الصور الذاتيه المعروفه
بالسلفي فلنتابع
ومع براعه الرئيس الامريكي نختم التاسعه
مع العناوين
اوكرانيا تعتبر الوثائق المسربه من
البنتاغون مزيجا من الصدق والكذب المستفيد
منها روسيا
الرئيس الصيني يوجهوا الجيش بتعزيز
تدريباته العسكريه وتحذيرات من حظر صيني
على اجواء تايوان
فرنسا تعلن صياحها من تصريحات ترامب حول
زياره ماكرون للصيف قبل ايام وتصفها
بالمبتدله
الحكومه الامريكيه تدعو لتنظيم قطاع
الذكاء الاصطناعي ووضع قوانين صارمه على
الشركات الضخمه
مشاهدينا التاسعه انتهت لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره طبعا كما كل ليله والان الى 360
وزملاء راويه وطاهر راويه وطاهر مساء
الخير ماذا لديكم مساء النور مساء الخير
ليان طبعا سنتحدث عن موضوع التسريبات
وقضيه ترامب المدعي العام بالقضيه يرفع
دعوه ضد عضو جمهوري وموضوع الوثائق السريه
للبنتاجون نناقش هذا الملف من زاويه
الموقف الروسي الذي اعتبر ذلك طبعا تضليلا
امريكيا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات